senator bernie sanders loon bag of
vermont has been the leading voice in
the United States for socialized health
care it's called for such a policy
amounts to this tweet he issued last
night quote people who can't afford
health care do not deserve to die this
of course has nothing to do with policy
and everything to do with an immature
worldview that suggests that government
contain every unfairness in life of
course no one deserves to die because
they can't afford health care but no one
deserves to die for any reason other
than their own evil criminality people
don't deserve to die of cancer people
don't deserve to die in car accidents
people don't deserve to die peacefully
in their beds in old age as Clint
Eastwood says an Unforgiven deserves got
nothing to do with it the question in
public policy isn't one of motivation
nobody right or left believes that poor
sick people deserve to die the question
is has the best increased access to
health care the right believes that
increase in supply is necessary in order
to create competition and therefore
lower cost and increase quality this
means deregulation the Left believes
that current supply must be
redistributed one of these used in every
single area of life has generated more
access to wealth and health one of these
uses generated less if there is a
question of morality attendant to health
care it isn't whether people deserve
death based on cost whether health care
providers can be forced to serve people
at a loss and whether doing so will help
more patients in the long run but
Sanders simplistic Kindergarten
sloganeering convinces a lot of people
who refuse to acknowledge the decent
intentions of their ideological
opponents it's not designed to achieve
better health care it's designed to
slander people who disagree about the
method for achieving better health care
without violating the rights of others
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
okay so we have a lot to get to today up
tune including president Trump is now
tweeting about Amazon and we're going to
talk about the media fight and we're
going to talk about Trump care so lots
and lots of things to talk about but
before we get to any of that I first
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at legacy box so if you are looking
to preserve your memories your childhood
memories you want your parents to
preserve their memories then you need to
go to legacy box right now I'm a
stickler for this sort of thing a few
years ago I used to help older folks
actually write their memoirs because I
thought it was so important to preserve
their memories for future generations
because without those memories you
really have not much left what legacy
box does it allows you to take all of
those old photos and all those old tapes
and translate those into a usable format
so you can access them anytime you want
you take you go to legacy box and then
you they actually send you a box and you
load the box with your old tapes and
your films and your pictures and your
audio recordings and you send it back to
them and then in a couple of weeks you
get them back on a DVD or a convenient
thumb drive so you can watch them you
can share them you can relive them
legacy box takes cares it takes care of
everything from beginning to end they
provide updates every step of the
process every single piece that you send
them they put a barcode on there so you
can trace where it is in the process
right now if you go to legacy box comm
flash pen you get a 40% discount on your
order legacy box comm slash pending get
that 40% discount on your order and
again this is something you're
definitely going to want to do so it
makes a great gift for a parents or a
loved one it ensures that your tapes
aren't moldering out there in the garage
getting ruined by the possibility of
flood or termites or something and
that's why you need legacy box comm so
go to legacy box complex pending is that
40% discount on your order terrific
terrific service so glad they exist and
of course use that legacy box / comm /
pen so they know that we set you okay so
yesterday there was a lot of hubbub over
the sort of media fight that took place
at the White House so Trump care and all
of its vagaries have now receded into
the background because honestly who
wants to talk about all of the
infighting over what amounts to a
significant cut to Medicaid future
growth but accepts Obama care central
premise I mean like nobody cares about
the details of Obama care all they know
is they don't like whoever touches it
which is why the polls today are showing
12 percent of Americans in favor of the
Senate health care version
Trump care so we'll get to all of the
the hubbub surrounding Matt but the
truth is both the right and the left
would much prefer it's much more
entertaining to talk about the media
fights that are currently happening so
Trump keeps saying that the media are
fake news and the news keeps saying that
Trump is a fake president so both of
them are equally the well I wouldn't say
they're equally wrong I think that the
news is more fake than Trump is a fake
president obviously Trump is the
president and media do sometimes report
fake news but what you really have right
now is this piece of Kabuki theater
where the only people who benefit are
the partisans on both sides and I'm
speaking as someone who is quite
partisan right I'm a conservative
I'm very partisan on behalf of my
viewpoint but this whole kind of
ridiculous play theater slap fight
between media and Trump is silly and the
reason it's silly is because the media
are going to do it the media are going
to do Trump's going to do it Trump is
going to do none of this is going to
change Trump wins points from smashing
the media around the media win points by
smacking Trump around and nothing
changes and then we just about it
that's basically the way this dynamic
works so yesterday was perfect example
of this you have Sarah Huckabee Sanders
who is in for Sean Spicer Sean Spicer
has been relegated to the outhouse he's
been locked there actually by President
Trump after Sean Spicer didn't do a good
enough job firstly relegated into the
bushes then you relegated him to the
outhouse Oh Sarah Huckabee Sanders has
now taken his place in the White House
press briefing room but naturally we're
allowed to take this press briefing
which is which is nice I mean it's nice
to be able to see the stuff visually so
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is the is doing
this and she's asked about a story we
discussed at length yesterday the CNN
story that accused Anthony Scotto
Moochie is a trump associate of
associating with evil Russian banks and
it turned out that that story was
complete crap there was nothing of
substance to it CNN had to retract the
story they fired the reporters who were
involved in the story and so Sarah
Huckabee Sanders is asked about this and
she just uses it as an opportunity a
legit opportunity to go after the press
with both barrels
here she goes III don't know that it's
that the response isn't good enough for
the president I think it's the constant
barrage of fake news directed at this
president probably that has garnered a
lot of his frustration you point to that
report there are multiple other
instances where that outlet that you
referenced has been repeatedly
wrong and had to point that out or be
corrected there's a video circulating
now whether it's accurate or not I don't
know but I would encourage everybody in
this room and frankly everybody across
the country to take a look at it I think
if it is accurate I think it's a
disgrace to all of media to all of
journalism I think that we have gone to
a place where if the media can't be
trusted to report the news then that's a
dangerous place for America and I think
it is a place that you're totally right
about all of us right she's totally
right about all of this everything Sarah
Huckabee Sanders says right here about
the media's coverage of Trump is exactly
right they put it forward a bunch of
fake news they violated their own
journalistic standards in order to do so
they're out to attack Trump they're out
to get Trump and pushing this Trump
Russia collusion hoax for a year now
even if Russia interfered in the
election which they probably did and
then when I say probably I mean they
almost certainly did because I haven't
seen the underlying evidence but I
believe our Intel community which says
that they did but even if that happened
there's no suggestion evidentiary that
the Trump campaign colluded with Russia
at least haven't seen anything yet so at
the year of hubbub for ratings and then
of course she was referring back to the
James O'Keefe video of a CNN producer
talking about how CNN had been pumping
up the Trump Russia stuff in order to
generate future ratings in order to
generate better rating so she's totally
right about all of us and then she goes
too far here is what Sarah how to be
gender says next if we make the
slightest mistake the slightest word is
off it is just an absolute tirade from a
lot of people in this room but news
outlets get to go on day after day and
cite unnamed sources use stories without
sources have you know you mentioned the
thermo G story before they had to have
reporters resign
okay so again this part is now a little
bit crazy because it is one thing to say
that they report stuff violate their own
ethical standards and all that I totally
agree totally agree the media is wildly
biased they hate Trump and they're out
to get to her all true all true but then
when she says well if we get anything a
little bit wrong everybody goes crazy
well you are the White House you are the
president I mean not to not
to try to be too fair-minded here but
there were those of us on the right
we're pretty critical of President Obama
I remember because I was one but I mean
we were on top of President Obama as
well we should have been the President
of the United States deserves scrutiny
and then she says news outlets go on day
after day and they excite unnamed
sources they use stories about sources
okay again the White House does is to
the White House leaks routinely to the
press the White House uses anonymous
sources a little bit if a critical and
then she says that the CNN story they
had to have reporters resign well that
conflicts with the idea that news
outlets don't see any ramifications for
it they do right I mean if news outlets
have to fire their reporters because of
the blowback after they'd write a bad
story that is a that is a ramification
that is a form of accountability you may
not think it's enough you may think they
were pressured into it but it doesn't
really matter bottom line is to pretend
the media is not being held accountable
by people like me people like you watch
the show people like the president is
just silly okay so but Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is into scoring points with the
Trump administration rather score points
off the media then actually promulgate
good policy at least openly like some
good policies happening but it's all
happening behind the scenes so what did
this do this prompts a guy named Brian
Karam of Sentinel newspapers so I guess
in a playboy reporters reporter for
Playboy and I would make a joke about a
playboy reporter being in the White
House briefing room asking questions
except that we've had a number of weird
people in the White House briefing room
asking questions and President Trump has
a picture of himself on the cover of
Playboy in his office so I can't really
mock that too much anyway Brian Sentinel
newspapers he meant pipes up and he goes
on just this rant against Sarah Huckabee
Sanders in the White House what you're
implying everybody right here right now
with those words you did this
administration has done that as well why
in the name of haven't any one of us
right or replaceable
and any one of us if we don't get it
right the audience has the opportunity
to turn the channel or not read it I
think you have been elected to serve for
four years at least there's no option
other than that
or added to ask you questions prime your
to provide the answers and what you just
did is inflammatory to people all over
the country who look at if they see once
again the president is right and
everybody
here is fake media and everybody in this
room is only trying to do their job okay
so the he says that and this enforce was
viral the entire meeti rescues aren't
champion now he is our champion yeah
except for the faculty because
everybody's just your friends do their
job we're all just trying to do our job
yes but what you consider your job to be
is getting from right I mean your job is
not just to cover the news for a lot of
the media the job is to get from get
that moment where you can finally
fulfill that leftist fantasy that trump
is gonna be thrown out on his ample
posterior right out of the White House
and into primum right so this who does
this benefit okay who does this benefit
well first and foremost it benefits this
reporter who gets to become a hero on
MSNBC he goes on MSNBC right after this
and he talks about how brave he was now
again I think that this is not
particularly brave because bravery
entails undergoing some sort of risk
okay saying saying things to Sarah
Huckabee Sanders is not exactly like
Martin Luther King in Selma brave it's
mostly like you mouthing off men getting
celebrated on MSNBC which is which is
virtue signaling okay here he is being
feeded they basically give them a medal
over on MSNBC this guy are they tellers
that that's that's why we're here is to
try and find out and there have been
what got me when you asked about what
got me rankle it's the fact that they
sit there and say we're dishonest in the
media and we're being dishonest
well there's consequences but I have yet
to hear anyone from this administration
is even admit a mistake and so it's a
little hard to take because the people
in that room I have a healthy respect
for I've been coming and going in this
room since off and on since the Reagan
administration there were you know those
people I have held up as heroes some of
the people that were here in addition
there are reporters who have given their
lives to get news to the public and it
be just labeled as dishonest and fake
media rankles me and I you know maybe I
lost my temper at that moment but it it
was a long time coming it was six months
I would like to see that taken off the
in just taken off the table and let us
talk about real issues let us ask our
questions quit hitting us with fake
media I mean everyone including
Breitbart that's in there has been
respectful they've asked
questions and the administration is not
often been forthcoming with what I would
say are factual answers so yeah I'm a
little Kannada then cuz yeah yeah sure I
believe about a thing cuz magic either
says love it like it's got it was a
human unrepaired up button oh
international cemetery ah
zero zero okay so this is to who
benefits first of all the media benefit
from this perception that they are
speaking truth to power right goes all
the way back to Sam Donaldson doing the
same thing with Ronald Reagan back in
the eighties and then who else benefits
will trump benefits obviously because we
on the right we hate the media we think
the media are totally full of crap but
does anyone benefit in terms of policy
well not really because it turns out all
the Acolytes of the media don't trust
Trump all the Acolytes do Trump don't
trust media and so we have nothing to
talk about really and the fact is that
bad media performance happens on both
sides it does happen on both sides like
I would prefer I said this before I've
said this many times I would prefer a
left media to cover Trump and a right
media to cover Obama because whoever is
most in opposition to the president
seems to me the person who is most
likely to actually keep that president
being held responsible like I would
rather have tough questions being asked
than this question from lifestyle I've
said is a Laura Ingraham publication
here's a life set reporter asking
question yesterday he was the news about
CNN's erroneous story about Anthony's
Karen Moochie
does the White House believe there are
other russia-related stories from major
elements that have not been retracted
and are just as false including the
February 14th story in The New York
Times about collusion between some Kent
Lane and Russia
which James Comey called into question
which many believe the CNN story was
based upon does the White House now
believe the news media have an
obligation to review stories on the
Russian Trump issue and retract question
we source story okay I mean it's a it's
particular though here's a softball tear
I just enjoy write it name all the
stories you think have been bad over the
past year again did all that what we
have to understand is consumers of
media's the media have an agenda
Trump has an agenda and their real
agenda here is to play play this lap by
game or both of them win points off of
each other that doesn't mean you should
trust the media over Trump it doesn't
mean you should trust Trump over the
media it means you should trust the
facts for the fact and understand the
game is being played on both sides is
much more about scoring points than it
is about actually achieving truth well
before we go any further honestly thank
you to our sponsors over at Indo chinos
so if you want a suit that just looks
the best a suit can look you need to go
over to Indo Chino that's because Indo
chinos a custom tailored says we're not
talking about they take a suit off the
rack and they make a few changes to it
we're talking about they make the suit
from scratch for you they make it easy
to get a perfectly tailored suit as if
at a fantastic price you can choose the
fabric I went into their their showroom
over in Beverly Hills you can choose
from hundreds of top quality fabrics
personalize your suit just the way that
you want it for work for wedding for any
special occasion you can either visit
the showroom they have them in a lot of
major cities or you can shop online at
endo Chino calm you pick your fabric to
pick your customizations lapels pleads
jacket linings it's really a lot of fun
and then you submit your measurements
you place your order and a few weeks it
comes right to you and then if they get
it wrong then they make it right so this
week my listeners can get any premium
Indo Chino suit for just three hundred
seventy nine dollars in Indo Chino calm
when entering Shapiro at checkout again
that's Indo Chino I ng o CH Ino calm
when you enter Shapiro a checkout that's
50% off the regular price from a
geometric premium suit again shipping is
free ENSO Chino calm promo code Shapiro
and again you get any premium suit for
three hundred seventy nine bucks plus
free shipping leather you can
off-the-rack suit like Macy's for and
probably cost more money than that here
you get one that is specifically
tailored to you so fits you perfectly
that's what endo Chino is therefore I
have an endo Chino suit it is my
favorite suit it is fantastic Indo Chino
calm and of course use that promo code
and that will ensure that you are
not only do they know that we sent you
but also it ensures that you get that
50% off the regular price for a
made-to-measure premium suit so 379
bucks enter Shapiro a check out again
Shapiro at check out okay so speaking of
media bias there are areas where I think
that the media bias is a little more
insidious believe it or not then even in
politics so I am an advocate of the
position that Andrew Breitbart used to
take which is a cultures upstream of
politics meaning that more people are
impacted by their views on politics by
culture than they are by actual politics
like there's a select group of people
who listen to this show and it's thank
God big and growing but it is not nearly
number of people who watch sports for
example or the number of people who
watch Entertainment TV the fact is that
if you look at views even among
Republicans from the time that Modern
Family premiered on gay marriage canal
there's like a thirty point drop in the
number of people who disapproved of gay
marriage in the Republican community
between Modern Family premiering and now
because people tend to follow culture
people tend to imitate culture and
imbibe culture this is where the media
bias is really the worst because in
politics there are some checking
mechanisms right I am a check and
balance on the media president Trump is
a check and balance on the media Sarah
Huckabee Sanders is a check and balance
on the media you yourself is consumer
you are aware of media bias so you are
now a check and balance on the media
this is not true when it comes to
cultural areas when it comes to cultural
areas there is no check and balance
because most of us don't even want to
think about the fact that the left is
infiltrating all of the areas of culture
that we inhabit and trying to twist them
to their own viewpoint so for me one of
my pet peeves is sports so I am a huge
sports fan I particularly enjoy baseball
and basketball although I do like
football as well but the three big
sports are my sports I wish I knew more
about hockey because I've been to a
couple hockey games and they're
wonderful but I don't know enough about
it to be a big fan I don't know enough
for the players I'd really have to sort
of engross myself in it but in any case
I'm also a tennis fan so I like tennis
and there's been a controversy that is
now broken out that is just ridiculous
and stupid over Serena Williams so we
talked about this a little bit yesterday
John McEnroe he's of course one of the
great men's players of all time he came
out and he said Serena Williams a great
player but Serena Williams is not as
good as men right Serena Williams is a
girl and that prompted Serena Williams
to begin tweeting about it because she
was now very very very very very very
mistress demonstrates again how things
work in the in the sports media
everything has to be politicized so she
tweets out Dear John I adore and respect
you but please keep me out of your
statements that are not factually based
I've never played any one ranked there
nor do I have time respect me and my
private is I'm trying to have a baby
good day sir I don't understand what her
having a baby had to do with the
question he was asked his direct
question we played it yesterday he was
asked a direct question about where
Serina would rank and he said she is the
best female player of all time and
people so why not the best player of all
time and then the media asked him to
apologize to hear the CBS anchors were
angry at McEnroe asking him to apologize
for it I felt in need from however
unfortunately and probably probably
defend myself I don't know just say what
I really felt I mean which is about what
I think she would be I think you're
referring to the fact that I said she'd
be about 700 in the world yeah I've got
a solution Gail though because I know
that you're friendly with Sarina and I
think I believe yesterday right now I'm
just waiting here we would like to
apologize no you really do need to
answer Charlie's pool what was it I
didn't learn you're right I wasn't a
library to do this yes it wasn't
necessary it was not nothing new
alacrity I didn't know what I didn't
know it would create you know giddy no
John if anybody ever I've said this now
I'd be richer already thanks no apology
just arena really I've listened I would
be happy to apologize arena yell if that
makes you feel better anyone I think
Serena's incredible I don't want
anything to go wrong with Serena because
she's pregnant I don't want to upset her
or whatever it was she's I think she was
doing it tongue-in-cheek as well and I
think the deeper the whole thing's
ridiculous this whole thing is just
ridiculous as in insane okay it's
totally that you've got the CBS anchors
berating and badgering over something
that is obvious perfectly obvious again
Serena Williams did play a a practice
match but I went like two hundred and
third in the world from one game off of
him one okay like no I'm sorry she is
not as good as the men because she is a
girl and that is just she's amazing she
kicked my ass but that has nothing to do
with whether she would be on the
professional men's sort in fact you know
who has said this in the past you know
acceptance and some woman named Serena
Williams your Serena Williams on David
Letterman a couple of years ago actually
it's funny because
marry he all he was been joking about
myself and him playing a match and I'm
like Andy seriously like are you kidding
me cuz for me tennis in men's and
women's centers are completely almost
two separate for it so I'm like if I
were to play Andy Murray I would lose
six oh six Oh in five to six minutes
maybe 10 minutes because there's no
enduro and honestly completely it's a
completely different foursome in our lot
faster and me and they did they serve
harder they hit high she's a different
game and I love to play women's tonight
I only want to play girls I don't want
to be embarrassed I would not do the
tour I wouldn't do really seen any
justice so Andy's stop it yeah we're not
I'm not going to let you kill me okay so
there she is admitting it okay because
it's true because it's true doesn't stop
those GPS anchors from going after max
how dare you suggest biological reality
that's just terrible actually my
favorite thing of the night last night
is a christina hoff sommers so the the
factual feminist friend of mine she was
tweeting out she was tweeting up i guess
it was a book segment from some feminist
queer theory book and and there was a
segment from some woman who thinks she's
a man as transgender man talking about
how she had given birth and the whole
the whole piece was a man kids birth and
so i tweeted back what via the urethra
like how would that work and it's
passing a hell of a kidney stone right
there because the fact is that men can't
converse gang only women can give birth
but visibly you speak basic biological
truths to now and suddenly you're it's a
problem like I'm up in Canada right now
I'm over in Toronto because I'm gonna
give a speech tonight and Jordan
Peterson who we're going to have to have
on the show when when studio is finally
set up totally Jordan Peterson has
basically been reamed out by his own
University by the government for having
temerity to say things like men are men
and women are women this is the way that
we are moving and in the media the media
are pushing that as hard as they
possibly can and then of course they are
firing every conservative they can get
their hands on Britt McHenry who was a
controversial figure because there's a
video of her getting angry at some sort
of car attendant at one point she was
fired and she came out
yesterday she said he s been fired me
because I'm conservative which is
perfectly plausible she said I mean I've
been openly conservative look how that
ends it up is what she tweeted out
yesterday which is correct
okay ESPN will fire people who are
openly conservative whether you're
talking about Mike Ditka or Curt
Schilling it doesn't seem to matter Curt
Schilling's great sin you recall with
the Curt Schilling at one point had said
that Isis was like the Nazis they fired
him right Mike Ditka's great sin is that
he didn't support President Obama oh
just so terrible unbelievable but this
is how culture bleeds down into politics
and that's why we have to fight back
against it no sports should be left to
sports they should not turn into the
political whims of the of the radical
left that's really stupid okay
we're going to continue by talking about
the latest on Trump care plus some
things I like things I hate and some
Bible talk but for that you're going to
have to subscribe so go over to daily
we're calm right now become a subscriber
for eight dollars a month you too can
subscribe over at daily wire.com you can
part the mailbag which will be doing on
Friday you can watch the rest of the
show live you can get Andrew Klavan
fantastic show live and be part of his
mailbag as well we have another show
that's going to be released in the very
near future as well you get all of that
when you become a daily wire member plus
if you go over if you want to become an
annual subscriber then you can for the
annual price you get a free signed copy
of book I wrote with my dad say it's so
all about baseball and fathers and sons
autographed by me Plus walk in your rate
whether your annual or just regular
subscriber lock in your rate right now
because the rates are going to go up on
July 10 so they're not going to go up
for people who are already subscribed
now is your window if you want that low
price and then make sure that you get
your subscription right now don't wait
until July 11 to do it okay so we're
going to continue over on over on our
site and then if you want to listen
later you can go check out iTunes or
SoundCloud and become a subscriber there
leave us a review we always appreciate
it we are the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
you